what up space fam goes in here from
anime abroad i'm back at it again to
discuss the new crazy one-piece chapter
and we got some truly epic straw hat
moments here so make sure to stay tuned
for this one if you do enjoy these
one-piece reviews and want to keep them
coming the best thing you could do is
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button until it's blue if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
which will be in two weeks feel free to
check out my growing one piece playlist
that includes videos on all the yonko
warlords supernova and more link that is
in the description also leave any
comments for videos suggestions you
would like to see
and now without further ado let's jump
into it spoilers
and all so this chapter is called and i
quote
this is otama end quote so you know tama
is going to shine in this one which is
not surprising because she has earned
mvp
for some previous chapters because of
how insanely useful she's been
and at only 8 years old but first we
stop by the flower capital to see what
dudes are doing on the ground as kaido's
moving castle approaches them
and people are enjoying themselves we
see otoko and tanguyama
the swordsmith as he explains that the
fire festival honors the dead
they light the bonfire in the hopes that
it will be visible in the heavens
and i like the fact that it's a
celebration even though it's honoring
the dead
it doesn't mean it has to be a solemn
affair toko who is only six years old
hopes her dad yasuy can see the fire
from heaven
after his execution and tengwyam assures
her that with the sky this clear he's
certain that he can
it's a beautiful moment but also one
filled with impending danger
for us because we know that the sky
probably won't be clear for long
because of floating islands and the like
tengoyama tells her that her dad
is probably watching intently to see
what becomes of his daughter
and his country at that point we get a
visual of the flying island in the air
and the fact that there's a giant skull
on top of it only adds to a sense of
impending doom oda definitely did a good
job with the juxtaposition between the
clear sky of the festival and the
close-up of kaido's moving castle i
really enjoy how
manga can make use of visual language in
this way just like you might see when
you're watching a movie we jump inside
the castle and go loving cipher pole
dude remarks how our straw hats and
friends refused to surrender despite the
loss of straw hat luffy i don't know how
everyone feels about this dude's go
metaphors but
i enjoy them a lot as he mentions 5 000
soldiers are no longer able to battle so
the forces should
be 24 000 kaido men to 3 000 luffy men
but pleasure and waiters on the live
floor turned against queen and when you
account for the four thousand of them
the total is twenty thousand kaido men
versus seven thousand luffy men
and as the title alludes to tama is the
key to turning more fighters to luffy's
side
so we can assume that the disparity
between the all-important
white and black go pieces will continue
to shrink
right now despite kaido beating luffy
the overall numbers are more favorable
to luffy's side than they were at the
beginning
this is how amazing the straw hats are
even if luffy and zoro are incapacitated
for the time being
they are able to not only stay in the
game but to continue to shrink the
difference in manpower it's absolutely
astonishing and truly highlights how
important a good crew
and good allies are the go metaphor is
so significant because
one piece and i'm not referring to the
title of the series here can't possibly
win
in go and one piece and this time i am
referring to the title of the series
unlike many others shonen for now at
least has done a good job
of showing that one overpowered
individual doesn't win wars but a strong
united army
that's something i really appreciate
about this series and i hope that oda
keeps it that way for as long as
possible if not forever
anyways cypherpol go dude calls the fact
that straw hat forces are doing so well
an
unexpected turn of events and yeah it
totally is and it's
why the straw hats as a whole are
legends being able to thrive against the
yonko's crew
even without the help of their captain
temporarily we then jump to the news
that momo has fallen too
as we saw last chapter unlike us they
assume this means that momo is done for
and now they think the samurai will lose
their resolve but as we saw with luffy
if you don't have the body as proof
these fighters won't fall for any tricks
that easily we then jump to the arguable
mvp trio of this chapter nami usop and
tama
they're running and nami's weather
weapon is talking as i mentioned last
time
seems zeus somehow made his way into it
and now we'll get more info about that
although nami temporarily jokes that
she's even more of a genius for creating
a talking weapon
zeus explains that it's him the one they
used to call zeus
when nami extended her weapon as he was
being eaten
it ended up absorbing his essence so to
speak the team up i wanted
so badly is here and we got it in an
even better way where now nami
is not just using something big mom
created but we get this new unique spin
on zeus which still serves to maximize
the effectiveness of nami's own weapon
i could not be happier with this turn of
events and although nami
jokes she didn't sign up for an annoying
sentient weapon
zeus did have that opportunity to prove
himself when he thought he really would
die
so i don't think it'll be too hard for
nami to forgive him for earlier events
where he turned against her
then right as bao huang is about to
announce momo's death
in order to try to lower samurai morale
she is interrupted by the appearance of
our straw hats
usopp then gets headbutted by none other
than ulti
man is this dino girl tough she's gotten
up
after the damage big mom dished out ulti
as if she didn't learn her lesson
again lays her hands on tama blaming her
for converting her
allies to the straw hat side even big
mom
nami tells her again to keep her hands
off tama
and then we start to see what the new
zeus is capable of
he turns into a kind of giant morning
star and slams into ulti
letting nami know she can use her usual
tact and zeus is just here to help with
cool new super powers
nami straight up says it's unbelievable
and this is a real
game changer nami way back in the
beginning wasn't really a fighter but
she's
become more and more of one as the story
went on and now with the amplification
of her zeus possessed weapon she's truly
become a fearsome fighter and i
love to see it happening zeus can even
share important info
like that ulti skin is crazy hard but
her insides must be messed up after big
mom's attack so she'll go
down with one strike of a thunderbolt
with his appearance
his wisdom and his power in this fight i
gotta give
zeus the mvp for this chapter but it's
the team effort that really shines here
nami can't use a thunderbolt attack
because it would hurt
tama too so usop launches an attack that
separates ulti from tama giving nami and
zeus the opening they need to launch
their attack
we then get probably the most hilarious
part in this chapter where
zeus emerges from the weapon as the
cloud we're used to seeing
nami calls out zeus but he says not
anymore
this is a new beginning and he asks for
a new name and nami in the heat of
battle suggests
cotton and then we just jumped to zeus
saying and i quote
i am zeus nami's right hand man brace
yourself end quote so
i'm happy to see that the name zeus will
stick because it's awesome but i'm so
glad
we got that scene nami's suggestion was
so bad
zeus didn't even address it and dropped
the idea of getting a new name
altogether
man i can't get enough of this dynamic
between these two
then we get another epic moment where
the huge thunderbolt
attack misses and ulti thinks it's over
she thinks she's won
but then zeus just hones in on her and
hits her anyways
now even a missed attack can be
redirected by zeus until it hits the
target
amazing stuff this seems to finally take
care of ulti
and having nami beat ulti even though
ulti was hurt already and even though
she had to rely on zeus is
so awesome people nami just beat a
flying
six member bao huang sees this and
instead of hurting our side's morale
she helps it big time by accident she
accidentally tells everyone that ulti
was beaten like page one
and that now two of the flying six
members have been defeated now many of
kaido's men
are nervous thinking that the straw hat
forces are backing them up into a corner
bao huang when told what's happening
even broadcasts the fact that she didn't
mean to broadcast
this suggesting to everyone that there
might be more bad news she's hiding
sasaki hush who and black maria all look
concerned and remember
drake already switched sides so only
three of the legendary flying six remain
that can't be comforting to hear for
kaido's men usop keeps being
invaluable by trapping bao huang in a
giant plant
allowing tama to use her to broadcast
herself to everyone including to all her
new animal-based followers
this speech is gonna be big but for now
we move on to kaido vs yamato a battle
yamato has been
itching to have no doubt kaido tells
yamato that luffy and momo are dead both
are definitely inaccurate statements
but it's still crazy to think how well
the straw hats are doing after kaido
seemingly took out luffy and momo even
kaido uses go
or chess-like analogies when he says you
should learn to protect your pieces to
yamato
kaido does not intend to let yamato
leave but yamato says
she's going to sail the seas with luffy
once again
11th straw hat vibes are strong right
here
roger had an odin on his crew why
wouldn't luffy have one as well
this fight gives us an interesting
dynamic where kaido despite everything
wants yamato to become the country's
shogun kaido seemingly wants yamato to
be his momo
but yamato will never accept that and as
we knew from the start yamato knows that
she can't beat kaido but that doesn't
mean she's not gonna help the cause in
any way she can
she proclaims that luffy is the one odin
was waiting for
and that she's just going to hold kaido
off until luffy gets back
not a small task at all even if she
doesn't plan to win and kaido says and i
quote don't expect me to go easy on you
yamato
end quote it's interesting stuff this
dynamic between father and daughter
clearly kaido is kaido and he's going to
fight but there are clues that he truly
wants yamato his child to be on his side
like the fact that he won't let her
leave
that he wants her to be shogun and so on
he's much less merciless
and more ready to forgive yamato for
going against him than many people
probably thought someone like kaido
would be
and because of these feelings yamato
despite not being
as strong as kaido is probably the best
person available to at least distract
him
until luffy can come back and that is it
yet another great
chapter let me know what you thought of
it and what you're expecting to see
next in the comments you can also let me
know if you think yamato is pretty much
confirmed 11th straw hat at this point
or if you still think that title will go
to someone else
and who was the mvp for you this chapter
i'm going to go with zeus as stated
my dudes made me so happy and made nami
deadly enough to defeat a flying six
member
albeit there are additional external
factors to her eventual victory but
still
she did it and i couldn't be happier
usopp was amazing too
that has to be said all in all one piece
is amazing right now and i can't wait to
see where we go from here
in two weeks but anyways if you do enjoy
these one-piece reviews and want to keep
them coming the best thing you could do
is
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button until it's blue if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos that's just
the way youtube works
and while you wait for the next chapter
which remember will be in two weeks
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all the yonko
warlords supernova and more link to that
is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon
and here on youtube who helped make
videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twigo himself alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
ingrata pate heffa al-jatal dr cortman
the toaster chi
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis baked buddhist cody hebert
and monkey d quilly and our pro hero to
your patrons
the one and only gilgamesh the red
red-haired raven angel cruz
anatoly kazatsuki very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks hinokami and water
joanne garcia ted note 10 fat boy games
corey mcgowan
metal mama deadly saint and soul rise
slice and dice
thank you all so much if you do enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
anime outbreak and becoming a patron
today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing people right here and you'll
even get access to our private patron
only discord where we talk about anime
life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you